Welcome to "Share Your World."
I'm Caroline and I love to travel.
While I'm not able to explore right now,
I'm inviting four other travel lovers
from different cultural
backgrounds to come together
and share our worlds with each other.
In this episode, we're sharing a few
of our favorite wedding traditions.
Every culture has its own
ways of tying the knot.
Here's one of my favorite
wedding traditions.
[Caroline] I'm Armenian and one
of my favorite Armenian wedding traditions
is when the bride and groom
are finally married.
When they go into their new home
that they're gonna be living in,
the groom's mother usually
places a bread called lavash,
which is traditional Armenian flatbread
over the newlyweds' shoulders.
And that's kind of to bless
them with bread and food
in the house.
And then one other thing, before
they step into their home,
they have to step on and break plates.
And that's kind of like
to get the bad luck out
of the house before they step in.
[Kasey] In Korea, there's a tradition
called a Pyebaek ceremony.
So Pyebaek is when you
get dressed in an old,
it's like a traditional hanbok.
[Katrina]- Kasey, so what
is, you called it a hanbok?
Did I pronounce it correctly?
Yeah, so a hanbok is a
traditional Korean costume
that they used to wear in
the palace dynasties
back in the day.
It's silk layers.
It's very colorful.
All of the women have dresses.
There are several skirts
that you wear underneath
and like a cute little jacket,
but it's like big sleeves
that are red, and white,
and pink, and gold.
And then the guys have also similar,
but pants with a vest and like a hat.
And it's just different layers,
but it's very silk and colorful.
[Debby] Sounds beautiful, wow.
[Katrina] It does sound beautiful.
So my cousin, John got
married and he wore blue.
And then my aunt and uncle
also wear blue-colored hanboks
because they're on the groom's side.
So they'll sit down on cushions
and then my aunt and uncle,
the groom's parents, will throw chestnuts
and they have a silk attachment
to her hanbok and they'll
both hold each side.
And they'll try to catch as
many chestnuts as possible.
And however many chestnuts you catch means
how many children you'll have.
[Jason] How many did your cousin catch?
[Kasey] Three.
[Jason] Three?
[Kasey] Yeah, and he's one of three, so.
[All] Wow.
Oh!
[Katrina] So I actually
recently got married.
My traditional Nigerian,
specifically Yoruba, ceremony
was in September last year.
The traditional wedding outfit for a bride
is typically the iro and buba.
Traditionally, it's kind of
like a boxy sleeved U-necked top
that's sewn in lace or aso oke.
It's a more fancy fabric
that we typically use
for special ceremonies.
It's not just for weddings,
but typically like weddings, graduation.
And then the buba is a skirt
that's wrapped around you
and folded over.
In more modern times, you're
not limited to it being a top
and a skirt that you wrap and fold.
There's just a little
bit more style in it.
And then you also wear a gele
that's wrapped really beautifully.
The bride's gele is typically wrapped
in a special way to make her stand out.
The planning was fun.
It was like 350 people, just for scale.
[Everyone] Wow!
[Katrina] Yeah, and that's not even
like a big Nigerian wedding.
At home, some people's weddings
in Nigeria are like 1,000 people.
[Debby] I don't even
know that many people.
[Katrina] I don't either,
but I think it leans
to the notion of 'it takes a village.'
So it's like a community
has built this child up.
[Caroline] It reminds me of
when ancient Armenian
weddings would happen.
It would take seven days and seven nights.
And everyone would just bring fruits
and whatever they can for the couple.
But it was kind of like
they were all involved
in this couple.
They were all involved in the marriage.
[Caroline] I wanna travel and
I wanna have a big wedding.
Well not me, maybe.
[Kasey] Yeah, I wanna go to a wedding.
[Katrina] Yeah, I wanna go to a wedding.
[Kasey] So I actually
have my friend's wedding
in London next year.
It was actually postponed from this year.
So I'm really excited to go.
What's nice is,
because we've been able to
travel domestically this year,
\
and I'm able to accrue a ton of points
which I can actually use
to redeem hotel nights
in the future for my
friend's wedding in London.
[Caroline] Let's all make a
vow to keep looking forward
to future weddings and trips.
And in the meantime,
we hope our video inspires
you to learn more about these
and other wedding traditions
from around the world.